archaeologist Miranda old house green
believes this murder is evidence of
druid sacrifice preserved in forensic
detail so this is where this man was
found 20 years ago and he was thought
quite by accident during peak cutting in
August 1984 the peat cutter suddenly
found what he thought was a branch of a
tree went down to look at it found it
was a limb he thought it looked
suspicious and the police were called
it was clearly part of a human body
now known as Lindo man the body found in
the bog was carbon dated to the mid 1st
century AD the time of the Roman
conquest
mummified in the peat his entire upper
body is extraordinarily well-preserved
from his skin which still shows visible
prints on his fingers to his internal
organs
whoo Lindo man was and exactly how and
why he died has long been a puzzle well
this person could accidentally fall into
the bog he might have been the victim of
a mugging but the forensic evidence
suggests to me that he was a victim of a
systematic killing we've got blows to
the head we've got a throat cutting and
to top it off we've got a garage so this
poor person seems to have been hit at
least twice on the head hard enough to
shatter the skull but not to kill him
outright then you've got a rope
tightened around his neck and at the
moment where the neck was constricted
the throat was cut which would cause an
enormous fountain of blood to rise up
from the from the cut throat all adding
to the performance the the theater of
the thing was the death of Lindo man a
ritual sacrifice at the hands of druids
if so his threefold murder bludgeoned
strangled and slashed across the throat
is the most detailed evidence yet of how
a druid human sacrifice may have taken
place and another clue was found in
lindo man's gut mistletoe pollen there
were four pollen grains of mistletoe and
we know that mistletoe is highly
significant for the Druids because we
have plenty of testimony saying that the
Druids cut down mistletoe
using a golden sickle from a sacred oak
tree so we can nail mistletoe and
associate mistletoe with Lindo and
therefore with the Druids
Althouse green believes that lindo men
may have been sacrificed to persuade the
gods to halt the Roman advance we think
the Lindo man died in the mid 1st
century AD and the Romans are pushing
Northwest from the southeast in order to
smash Anglesey it's a time of great
crisis and yet again we have the idea of
a sacrificial killing when people's
backs are up against the wall when it is
essential that the Romans are stopped
from smashing this holy of Holy's of the
Druids
for this sacrifice the Druids select a
special victim a young Celtic aristocrat
we know from the forensic evidence
studying the body of lindo man that he
was of high status his fingernails were
manicured he was neatly shaved he was in
the prime of life
he'd been groomed for this
there would be Scouts in the southeast
warning people in the northwest that
this was coming the lesions were coming
something had to be done to stop them in
their tracks and what better way than
sacrificing a high-status nobleman
if the sacrifice of a nobleman is meant
to hold back the Roman advance the
gesture fails